vamos a introducirnos a la idea de lo
que es una ecuación diferencial y como
veremos las las ecuaciones diferenciales
son súper útiles para modelar y simular
muchos fenómenos y para entender cómo es
que funcionan pero pero veremos eso
mucho más adelante por ahora pensemos en
qué es una ecuación diferencial verdad y
quizás estoy relacionado con el concepto
de ecuación aquí lo interesante es
digamos el término diferencial y para
poder explicarlo vamos a irnos
directamente con un ejemplo digamos que
yo tengo que la segunda derivada de una
función y más dos veces la derivada de
nuestra función que es tres veces
nuestra función verdad y esto es una
ecuación diferencial es una especie de
relación que hay entre las derivadas de
una función y la misma función ahora
podríamos utilizar también la anotación
la anotación digamos de funciones que ya
conocemos verdad la segunda derivada de
mi función f que depende de x
más dos veces la derivada de la función
fx es tres veces la función de la que
estábamos hablando muy bien o también
podríamos utilizar la anotación de la
ebn y la anotación de live
nos dice la segunda derivada vamos a
utilizarlo con la segunda derivada de ye
respecto de x ambas veces más dos veces
la derivada de con respecto de x tiene
que ser tres veces nuestra función ya
muy bien y estas son tres formas
distintas de expresar esencialmente lo
mismo que es una ecuación diferencial
verdad déjenme hacer bien está allá de
estas tres son exactamente lo mismo y la
pregunta interesante es la siguiente
podemos realmente encontrar una función
tal que al derivar la dos veces y
sumarle dos veces su derivada sea tres
veces esa función
entonces en caso de que podamos
encontrar dicha función podemos decir
que justamente la solución a la ecuación
diferencial
justamente una función o podrían ser
incluso funciones verdad no
necesariamente tiene que ser sólo una
como veremos más adelante ahora quizás
el concepto más familiar que tenemos
relacionado con una ecuación diferencial
es la ecuación algebraica y quizás
podría decir una ecuación tradicional
verdad pero la verdad es que las
ecuaciones diferenciales tienen muchas
digamos tradición justamente en la
historia de las matemáticas verdad así
que creo que es más preciso decir una
ecuación algebraica muy bien tengo una
ecuación algebraica y por ejemplo
podríamos pensar en esta es una que
digamos ya hemos trabajado mucho x
cuadrada más 3 x más 2 igual a 0 en una
ecuación cuadrática entonces cuando
queremos encontrar las soluciones a una
ecuación cuadrática en realidad sabemos
que son parejas o más bien tenemos una
pareja de números que resuelven es esta
ecuación cuadrática verdad de hecho
podemos encontrar la de la siguiente
forma
factorizar y sería cosa de pensar dos
números que multiplicados me den 2 y
sumados nos den 3 esos son dos
1 verdad esto es igual a 0 entonces de
aquí podemos obtener que las soluciones
a esta ecuación algebraica es menos 2 o
podría ser menos 1 verdad entonces aquí
como podemos darnos cuenta las
soluciones a esta ecuación algebraica
son dos números a diferencia por ejemplo
de las ecuaciones diferenciales en donde
las soluciones no sólo son números en
realidad tenemos todas todas una función
que es solución a la ecuación
diferencial y ahora vamos a hacerlo un
poquito más tangible quiero que que
veamos cómo se ve una solución de una
ecuación diferencial y también vamos a
ver que a menudo podemos encontrar no
sólo una podemos encontrar muchas
soluciones ok entonces digamos aquí
vamos a verificar lo siguiente si
nosotros consideramos consideramos la
función de uno de x igual a ea la menos
3x esta es una solución a la ecuación
diferencial es decir si nosotros
sustituimos en ésta
igualdad se va a cumplir verdad entonces
te invito a que hagas ahorita una pausa
cálculo es la primera derivada y la
segunda derivada de esta función y que
verifiques que en efecto esta igualdad
se da
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste toda
una pausa y pudiste realizar el problema
ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos muy bien
calculamos la primera derivada de 1 en
este caso pues hay que utilizar la regla
de la cadena verdad tenemos que derivar
que a la menos 3x con respecto a menos 3
x eso simplemente nos da a la menos 3x y
luego derivamos menos 3 x eso nos da
simplemente menos 3 verdad y esto fue
simplemente usar la regla de la cadena
ahora si queremos encontrar la segunda
derivada de esa función de 1 volvemos a
derivar esto que tenemos arriba y será
justamente igual verdad tenemos un menos
3 y al derivar esta expresión digamos
saca otro menos 3 que en conjunto nos da
9 que a la menos 3 x verdad y esto sólo
fue una práctica de la regla de la
cadena ahora bien ya tenemos la función
la derivada y la segunda derivada ahora
podríamos ver qué pasa así o más bien
podríamos verificar que esta igualdad se
da entonces tenemos la segunda derivada
de nuestra función sería
9 a la menos 3 x y luego sumamos dos
veces menos tres era la menos 3 x que en
realidad lo podríamos poner como menos 6
al menos tres equis y nosotros queremos
ver si eso es igual a tres veces nuestra
función que es tres veces a la menos 3 x
muy bien y aquí inmediatamente podemos
ver que 9 a la menos 3 x menos 6 era la
menos 3x son justamente 3 a la menos 3 x
verdad y en efecto nos da justamente lo
que buscábamos verdad que era 3 a la
menos 3x y por lo tanto esta función ya
no es una solución de la ecuación
diferencial pero eso no significa que
sea la única solución verdad y de hecho
vamos a ver que puede haber otra por
ejemplo la función de 2 de x iguala a la
x la exponencial sencilla como la
conocemos y podemos ver que su primera
derivada es justamente ella misma verdad
esa es una de las propiedades
fundamentales de la función exponencial
ahora también podríamos calcular la
segunda derivada de la deie 2 perdón y
volvería a hacer
a la equis entonces inmediatamente
consideramos la segunda derivada que es
a la equis más dos veces la primera
derivada más dos veces la primera
derivada que es a la equis y esto
claramente son tres a la equis que es
tres veces nuestra función verdad
entonces también fue una solución de la
ecuación diferencial entonces todo esto
fue un muy buen inicio en los próximos
vídeos vamos a explorar más sobre todo
esto veremos cómo se ven las soluciones
de una ecuación diferencial qué clases
de soluciones existen y qué técnicas
tenemos para poder resolverlas y
visualizar las y sobre todo vamos a
tener todo un arsenal de herramientas
para poder trabajar con ellas